I love you black man I love you black
man I love you black man I love you
black man I love you black I love you
black man I love you black man I love
you black man I love you black man I
love you black man I love you black man
I love you black man I love you black
man I love you black man black man I
love you yeah do you feel left
trying to fight
we like tank tops we like Instagram
likes they'll be smashing your check
[Music]
we are like scared
I love you black man I love you black
man I love you black man I love you
black man I love you black man I love
you black man I love you black man I
love you black man I love you black man
I love it I love you black man I love
you black man I love you black man I
love you black man I love you black man
I love you black man I love you black
man I love you black man I love you
black man I love
thank you
that's not what they meant when they
said black lives matter
you [ __ ] try to sit on their
face we can't breathe
I'm just
saying bro that's fine
I'm not even gonna lie bro the other day
I was on prawn hub
and I was playing this video
and as the dude was busting on the white
girl's face he's had black guys man
Reckless knitter
that [ __ ] made me laugh pretty hard
yeah it made you laugh pretty hard I
mean pause
I'm not going to be here sjw and act
like my erection was lost
because that did not happen you know
Sean King somewhere over there God the
way your penis stood is the way you
haven't been standing up for black women
like yeah I'm not doing all that but I
won't lie that's just kind of fun you
can spray it with white stuff black
lives matter whoa that's a lot I don't
know what it is it's cringe yeah that's
what I know try to put your put in words
what bothers you mental health
thank you
I'm sticking by that well you didn't
even got mental issues it's not as DS
listen at illness
but there's something
what
attention seeking attention is not
mental health it depends to what degree
you think everybody who's on Tick Tock
attendancy has got mental health it
depends to what degree the degree of
what you're doing the girl that was
showing a boom boom attention thinking
mental health it depends on the degree
I'm not saying everybody's on there
that's off I'm not anyways I'm gonna go
back to my earlier statement I'm not a
psychologist I don't know that's [ __ ]
cringe that's that's what I know okay
well since you brought up I'm gonna say
this I feel like people use a mental
health label for too many things like so
people just engage in shitty Behavior
true they're not due to some kind of
mental deficiency true people being
attention seeking is not a mental health
disorder you're right you know you're
right no you're right no this is just
[ __ ] cringe Behavior that's virtue
signals you're right that's what I'm
saying I'm gonna go back to my earlier
statement
[ __ ] cringe here's a hypothetical I
would rather someone say they hate me
than say this absolutely
why is that
that's that that's what I've been trying
to ruminate on why would I prefer
somebody who [ __ ] detests me than
someone who does this cringe [ __ ] I
believe that when someone's like I I
hate you
it feels more real
than this okay maybe it's I can
understand that you know I can
understand that I can understand that
that black that you that's me I can
understand that where black people has
been in the the the world that I can
understand that I can understand people
hating me and I'm like okay that's fair
I I understand I can avoid that already
it's probably a me thing and already the
fact that I have a problem with
compliments
genuine compliments I have a problem
with and that's the me problem
mental health that's a me problem it's
not a mental issue it's not an illness
but it's like you know PTSD and this and
that so it's mental whatever okay
whatever so genuine compliments I have a
problem with
when it's like that
is this reinforces why I have a problem
with genuine compliments the reason I
have a genuine compliments because I
have a PTSD from when I was a kid
everything was a joke I was a bullied I
was this and that and whenever some
people showed me love it was often to
not psych remember the psych thing the
psych era I lived through that so when
it's a genuine compliment I'm like okay
so what's what's the back hand what's
what's coming next
and that because whenever someone gives
me a compliment I think it's it's not I
think it's an attack is coming out the
PTSD is coming out with a backhand like
I always expect the worst right that's
when it's a genuine compliment when is
that I already know it's fake right and
now I'm living and I'm like yo you you
okay you play play like that yeah okay
that's a game to you yeah so that so
that's why so that I hate you I can deal
with that that's why my Instagram I
wrote some [ __ ] at some point and it was
I didn't know it was as deep as it was
right I didn't know it was that deep but
it actually was because I said something
like and I said something in a video and
then I put in my Instagram and it was
I could take a punch better than I could
take a hug
okay and that's why cause I could deal
with that I could pop and weave I could
deal with that I could you know or I
could just take it pop okay [ __ ] wow
yeah a hug or someone randomly loving me
and so we love them like
what you trying to do was this a punch I
know I know what it's for I know what
the use is I know what it is I know I
know I know that or maybe it punches
your love language no it's not
and if it is stop
stop don't do that
don't don't do that
stop it stop don't I even do it for real
don't do it okay but I could deal with a
punch a hug I don't know what what you
can get you can't you can't trick me
with a punch
you punch me I know what a fan is
aggression I know what to do I know
what's the mode
you could use a hug or you could use
affection to get some [ __ ] yeah I know
what you're saying yeah so when you do
it like that I know it's not real and
then it kind of pisses me off so if you
wanted me to put in the words that's
what it is
I always said this I always knew where I
stand with like folks who were on that
end of the spectrum so if they say I
hate you I'm like cool I'm kind of used
to that like I know where you stand it's
always been the people closer to me
politically that always made me feel a
little uneasy and that's what this
reminded me of oh yes yes black people
were here so I don't think so [ __ ] I
don't think so quite liberal eventually
I don't think so I don't believe you
but how quickly you locked the doors
when I was walking by your car yeah I
thought it just didn't feel right yeah
maybe I'm wrong please that's what this
reminds me of it's over and also just
something funny about seeing like the
black voices and the white voice people
dubbed over it so cringe but hey you
know
liberal lyrical black face maybe I'm
just too old the whole Tick Tock Trends
a lot of them just make me Quinn but
maybe y'all didn't feel that okay but if
any black man is showing you love
because you did this I guarantee you
it's because they trying to get some
[ __ ] that's it they're trying to get
some [ __ ] listen when we see a white
girl and she says oh my God I love
basketball [ __ ] like yeah we like
white girls too that's what they think
that's it when you're like oh my God I'm
gonna do some volunteerism in Africa
[ __ ] are thinking like yeah we like
some white [ __ ] too that's what they
thinking so just in case some black
people showed you love for this cringe
just know what it's for it's because
they trying to [ __ ] you
that's all I got anything else no I'm
good all right listen if you guys
enjoyed today's video let us know how
much you love black men please please
put in the comments uh if you love black
men put in the comments uh that's it
imagine other people in the comments is
just right I love you black man and it
starts a whole other Trend and they're
like yo stop doing that [ __ ] yeah if you
guys want to go on other YouTubers
channels
go to PewDiePie's latest video just all
of you I love you black man and I'll
vote I love you black man just do it
who would it be anybody there's got to
be someone white it makes it funnier yes
yes
H through H3
that's a good one that's you that's a
good one that's you yeah that's you
too late